all right here with reaction the co-host
of the bottom line on our sister network
uh the Fox Business Channel Sean Duffy
is here
[Applause]
also joining us former GOP gubernatorial
candidate Tudor Dixon great state of
Michigan tutor I really wanted you to
win that race badly and I hope you
continue your pursuit of public golf
office that would be good absolutely
you know as I as I look at this I may
surprise this audience here a little bit
I think that because remember Democrats
they want to impeach you if you if if
you breed the wrong air they impeach
Donald Trump over uh calling president
zielinski saying be responsible with the
money that the American people send you
so I think the right thing for her to do
would be to reach into her pocket pay
the thirty thousand dollars for the
ticket and say that's it at the end of
the day everyone agree or pay it back
Peter Dixon what do you think
you know I would have much preferred AOC
to go there and crash the met you know
the if she's a true activist why is she
going there in a fancy gown you know
that all of the rich people said it'll
be so ironic if we dress her up and say
tax the rich how cute we'll bring her
along what she should have done let me
give her a few tips on activism go there
not invited show them what the goodie
bag looks like and says this is what
happens to the rich but no she becomes
the rich she goes there in the Gown she
takes the goodie bag she deserves all
the bad press she's getting she is a she
is not very good at activism what should
the penalty be Sean well first off you
can't accept as a member of Congress
ethically uh the value of a ham sandwich
right I mean you can't take any gifts
and the fact that you you laid the list
of whether it's the dress the shoes uh
the ticket
um so by the way thirty thousand dollars
for an event no thank you I don't want
to go by the way you want to text all
these rich liberals who are by the way
leaving New York and they're going to
Florida right there I know
um but listen I mean this is part of the
course rules for for ye and not for me
John Kerry
um Bill Gates they want you to ride your
bike and they want you to cook on a on a
uh I love Davos they all fly in a
private jet to Davos and tell us we
shouldn't eat meat big places on the big
places on the beach you know massive um
massive homes so again this is hypocrisy
at its finest and so I think the
Congress should investigate it she's not
going to lose her seat but she should be
forced to pay this back and by the way
if you look at liberals and by the way
your crowd is great you guys are
classic do not take blame yourself you
blame it on a staffer that didn't pay
the bill for you I never had a staffer
who had access to my bank account my
wife did but not a staffer right it's
your fault not the staffer's fault tutor
what should the penalty be
well she should be publicly embarrassed
like this she should
she's doing this everybody knows you
can't take these gifts you can't take
any type of gift whatsoever like Sean
just said this is outrageous that she
would come out but isn't this so typical
of these young liberals to come out and
go it wasn't my fault yes it was take
credit for what you did wrong and fix it
just fix it yeah well I think now the
question is I want to survey the crowd
if I can and I want to ask you a simple
question how many of you think her
paying back the money is a punishment
enough
how many of you wanted to should you be
kicked out of Congress is that what you
are
you're right we have a great crowd
tonight
well it's going to be interesting I will
say this the double standard though this
I think this is why this crowd is saying
this because if you're Republican
you'll get arrested for jaywalking or
spitting on the sidewalk if you're a
Democrat like Hillary Clinton or Joe
Biden or zero experienced Hunter you get
away with everything and there's no
consequences at all but but to tutor's
point you know had she crashed the party
and shown the gift bags and all the rich
people there that's one thing or if she
saw this what do they call those Swag
Bags right I don't know I never get one
right you know it's not like look at me
I don't I'm not invited to anything yeah
neither am I but had she gone and said
you know what I'm not going to be
treated differently I believe in equity
I believe that people should be treated
fairly I see people in masks I'll put a
mask on or I'll demand before I go
everyone takes their mask off because
the working staff of the of the Met Gala
shouldn't be treated differently than
those who attend the gala but that's
exactly what happened she's not a
warrior for the middle class and for
low-income Americans she's an elitist
who wants to be treated like an elitist
all the while selling herself as a
middle class Warrior for the poor uh
thank you Sean great to see you food
addiction great to see you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else